[Music]
while more and more series about the mcu
have been released on disney plus
it is still rather quiet in theaters
however this will change
soon as the first movie of phase 4 black
widow will hit theaters this year
and then everything will start moving
fast one of the top titles is thor love
and thunder
the film is already said to be one of
the biggest in the mcu and the cast
looks
very promising but what will the fourth
movie of the god of thunder be about
what kind of plots are already known and
who will be the villain
well we've dealt with all these
questions and compiled the answers for
you
in this video be warned though this
video may contain some spoilers from the
mcu the film will take place in the
midst of phase 4 and will most likely be
released in us theaters on may 6
2022 chronologically it can be placed
between doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and black panther
wakanda forever
the events will of course take place
after end game although it will
certainly be interesting to see whether
they occur prior to guardians of the
galaxy vol 3
or after as we saw the end of avengers
end game thor sets out on a journey with
the
asgardians of the galaxy in order to
protect the universe
in the process the first teasing between
star-lord and himself occurs regarding
the captain's question
since the guardians will definitely play
a role in thor 4 it remains exciting to
see
as to when the movie will be set
quite a lot is already known about the
cast first the filming has been going on
in australia since january
and wrapped last week so some photos
have already been leaked on twitter and
similar sites
second marvel has also released some
details through official media channels
looking at the list of names there's a
lot to look forward to
and who would have guessed it chris
hemsworth is once again slipping into
the role of the god of thunder and even
his beloved jane foster
is back on the big screen after a hiatus
in thought 3.
this time however natalie portman plays
a special role
after director taika waititi handed her
the mighty hammer mjolnir at the 2019
comic con
it became clear that she will no longer
be the shy scientist but that
she will turn into mighty thor the two
of them are supported not only by all
guardians of the galaxy but also by the
new ruler of asgard
the valkyrie who has been fighting in
the mcu since ragnarok she will again be
played by tessa thompson
also back are jaime alexander as lady
civ sean gunn as crackling and of course
white td himself as the quirky cork
it is also certain that there will be a
few cameo appearances similar to those
in thor
3. a lot of fans were quite surprised
when matt damon is loki sam nila's odin
and chris brother luke hemsworth as thor
suddenly appeared as a small stage play
in asgard
they will get additional support and
love and thunder melissa mccarthy has
been hired to portray the evil sister
gila we're already looking forward to
that scene also confirmed is russell
crowe as
zeus whether this role is a serious one
or just another easter egg for the fans
we still don't know for sure
it's been a long time since we got a
seam in a superhero movie but the time
has finally come up again
christian bale has been confirmed as the
villain in though 4.
provided he is at least half as
convincing as he was in the batman dark
knight series we can
definitely look forward to some great
acting he will embody gore the god
butcher
we'll take a closer look at gore's
entire background later he has
connections to many characters in the
mcu which we've already met it is
interesting to note that after the dark
knight rises bale never wanted to be in
a comic book adaption again
bale feels the genre is too boring and
he always described wearing the costume
as
well let's call it confining taika
waititi however was able to persuade him
to reconsider his decision with his
character
and above all a very good script
however it is not yet known whether tom
hiddleston will play a part as loki
again
what is clear is that the loki of the
original timeline is dead
however as we know another one escaped
with the help of the tesseract and now
has his own series which will be
released on disney plus on the 9th of
june
this may have an impact on the upcoming
thor movie on several levels especially
considering natalie portman's new role
though we'll talk more about that at a
later date we would definitely be glad
to see the two brothers reunited even
though the loki from the other timeline
is not yet as jasmine as his dead self
the mighty thor line will play an
important and big role in the upcoming
film
in it jane foster develops breast cancer
and proves herself worthy of carrying
the harry mjolnir based on her deeds
it is believed that she gets cancer
because of her contact with the ether
the more she uses her newly acquired
powers the worse the tumor inside her
becomes
while titi thinks that this is a very
interesting approach in the comics but
he hasn't yet confirmed that he will do
it that way in the movie too
but how does she obtain the hammer in
the first place the mjolnir which we saw
in ant game was eventually returned to
its timeline by cap there are two
theories about this
the first would link up with a loki
series in this one loki works for the
time variance authority
has to fix errors in the timelines
however we know far too well that he
often pursues his very own goals
so it would be conceivable that he comes
in contact with the initial timeline and
brings back the powerful weapon from
another timeline into this one
the second theory would be that we are
not dealing with a jane foster from the
old movies at all
but that she also enters the main line
from a different one
however in that case she would only do
that after she has turned into mighty
thor
also an important element in the movie
is said to be the love stories
sure the first thing that comes to mind
is the romans between thor and jane
but there are a growing number of people
saying that the fierce valkyrie embodied
by tessa thompson will finally
find her love even though her sexuality
hasn't been detailed to this point we do
know that she's one of the first lgbtq
characters in the mcu
oh by the way the first homosexual
character in the mcu will be in the
movie
eternals but now let's talk about the
villain gore the god butcher he was
first introduced in the comics in 2013
and has been one of thor's most
dangerous
enemies ever since gore lived on a very
religious planet
upon the death of his parents in an
accident he renounces the gods and
henceforth moves into exile
when he then learns that such beings do
indeed exist yet they did not help
protect his family he
vows bloody revenge this he wants to
perpetrate with his powerful sword all
black
this sword was forged a long time ago by
the evil god no
he also decapitated the celestial we
already met in the movies
namely the one from whose head nowhere
emerged using the power of the sword and
the celestial he then created the
symbiotes we know from venom
therefore it could be that this will be
the first time that there will be a
hinted connection between
venom and the mcu know stranded on the
planet of gore when the letter learned
that he was a god he's slating with his
own sword
and sets off on his journey conceivably
he would handle the thor or jain and the
others would rush to assist the
respective one apart from that there is
no connection between
gore and mighty thor in the comics so
ytt can let his creativity run free
as has often been mentioned taika white
hitti is once again script writer
director and
actor all in one thus he has also
achieved great success on the latest
part of thor ragnarok and made it the
most successful movie of the series to
date after production had to be
postponed time and time again due to the
ongoing crisis
filming started on january 26 2021 at
fox studios australia in sydney
and the working title the big salad the
most exciting aspect is the camera
technology used to shoot the new film
it is based on stagecraft technology
which was already used in the disney
series the mandalorian
instead of standing in front of a green
screen the actors stand in front of led
video walls that display the setting
on the one hand this has the advantage
that shooting no longer has to take
place in many different locations around
the world but instead small camera teams
take images in advance
in addition the actors can see their
surroundings differently than with green
screen
and thus better anticipate their role
taiga waititi and chris hemsworth also
joked around a bit and posted their
first official poster for the film which
shows
well only them on social media hemsworth
added that the budget for the thor love
and thunder poster was calculated really
tight
but the message is clear lots of love
and lots of thunder
to conclude this video we have gathered
a few fun facts about the production
and the actors for example with his
fourth movie
thor is now the only mcu character to
have so many
standalone movies to his name the cast
includes five oscar winners namely
christian bale matt damon natalie
portman taiga waititi and russell crowe
including bale and crow three actors
have already moved from dc to marvel
after michael keaton
it will be the 29th film in the marvel
cinematic universe
chris hemsworth who's playing the role
of thor for the eighth time achieved his
largest physique to date for this movie
weighing 105 kilos
he had to eat 8 times a day just to
maintain the weight he gained
alright enough talk from us now it's
time for your opinion how hyped are you
for the new thor movie we cannot wait
for may 2022
after all ytd stated that it'll probably
be the best
mcu movie of all time are you missing
anyone among the current cast that you
would like to see and
what are your thoughts on the plot let
us know in the comments section if you
like this video please don't forget to
give it a thumbs up
[Music]
you